في حدث اليوم نتحدث عن الزياره التي
يجريها الرئيس الصيني الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لجانب هذه القمه السعوديه
الصينيه والقمه العربيه الصينيه والقمه
الصينيه الخليجيه هو الذي تحدثينها طبعا
ثلاث ايام تحتضنها الرياض سعيد بان يكون
معي لندن الزميله الصحفي زيد بن كامل
وسائل الاعلام السعوديه هل هي فعلا
تاريخيه
والله اهلا مساء الخير اخي توفيق السيد
المشاهدين اعتقد انها تاريخيا لانها تحمل
عده مظامين يعني هي
كازياره وتحتضن الرياض قناه قمم
نسوان القمه السعوديه الصينيه والخليجيه
الصينيه والعربيه الصينيه التحمل المبيدات
كبيره جدا واعتقد انها يعني لاول مره تحدث
ان الرئيس الصيني يعني يزور السعوديه
وزاره السعوديه
كبدا شركات استراتيجيه بين الصين وبين
الدول العربيه التي تفتح هذا الاخلاق لها
عن المملكه العربيه السعوديه تقدر انها
صحيح ان هذه زياره تاريخيه ليه لكن ما
تحملها ايضا كذلك هذه الزياره من ملفات
المهمه
لسؤال للمملكه العربيه السعوديه او ايضا
للمنطقه بشكل كامل لكن هناك ما يمكن لا هو
ان يسيل لعاب الشركات الصينيه عندما نسمع
بميزانيه 500 مليار دولار
لليوم اكيد ان الصينيين سيهرولون المملكه
العربيه السعوديه له
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بعكس هذه علاقه مصالح وتجدد مصالح بينها
وبين السعوديه وليست يعني الرئيس
الصيني
اعتقد ان هي المصلحه التي تهرول اكثر من
الرئيس الصيني لمصلحه دائما الدول تبحث عن
المصالحها وبعدين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
لها سنوات طويله جدا وهناك ايضا استثمارات
او متبادل ايضا تجاري واقتصاد بينها وبين
السعوديه خلال خمس سنوات الماضيه ميزان
التجاريه يعني اكثر من 300 مليار تخيل هذا
رقم ما هو سهل السعوديه ايضا اكثر من اكثر
الدول التي لها علاقات همم يعني تجاريه
بينها وبين الصين وايضا شركات يعني نحن لا
السعوديين مستمرين في الصين السعوديه لها
ثلاث مرات في الصين وانا في المقابل ايضا
الصيني في السعوديه طب هذه هي علاقه
استراتيجيه تكامل بين السعوديه تحديدا
صالح الطرفين الطرف السعودي وطرف الصيني
ايضا كذلك طيب زيد بنكمل خلينا ندخل الان
في سر الموضوع لان المشاهد العربي
بالتاكيد اعتاد على شيء هو الارتباط
السعودي بشكل حصري تقريبا مع الولايات
المتحده الان نسمع تنوع شركات الان حتى
هناك جراه حتى في الحديث مع الشريك
الامريكي هناك علاقات مع روسيا رغم معارضت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الان على
علاقه مع الصين رغم طبعا تحفظ قال
الولايات المتحده الصين هل يمكن ان نتحدث
الان عن استقلاليات تامه في السياسه
الخارجيه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
اولا السياسه السعوديه هي مستقله تامه
وليس ليس اليوم من اول ما تاسست المركبه
السعوديه والحوادث كثير والشواهد كثيره
يعني انا نانسي ايضا المشكله في التامينات
بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بسبب الصفقه التي تمت
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه والصين فيما
يسمى صور يحيى الشمس
وايضا كذلك يعني امتدت
هذه وبين الصين وايضا نفس الوقت هناك
شراكه بين السعوديه وبين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هسه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تنظر لمصلحه ثانيه صالح المملكه العربيه
السعوديه صحيح لديها علاقات مهمه وعلى
علاقات استراتيجيه بينها وبين الدول مثل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا لكنها
ايضا لديها علاقه مهمه وشراكه مستمره
بينها وبينها بين الصين احنا ناس ايضا
مثلا الملك عبد الله حينما تولى الحكم في
السعوديه اول دوله الصين وليست روايه
المتحده الامريكيه وهذا لا يعني ان
السعوديه يعني لديها خلاف عميق كبير جدا
بينه وبينه المتحده الامريكيه ممكن هناك
خلافات السعوديه دائما تحدث هذه الخلافات
بين الدول وبين الحلفاء حتى كذلك لكن تبقى
الدوله لديها سياده ولديها ايضا اراده
انها تعرف متى مصلحتها اين تجد مصلحتها
حتى لو كان الخلاف مع الخلفاء وكان خلافه
شديده وليست هذه المره تكون فيه خلاف بين
السعوديه بيننا المتحده الامريكيه حتى
الان الرئيس تصريحات همم الجانب الامريكي
ايضا يعني تصريح متضاربه يعني امس كان
يتحدثون عن شيء ان هذه سياده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولديها مصالحها واليوم
يتحدثون ايضا هناك ماذا يريد الرئيس
الصيني ان يفصل للمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
واعتقد ان هناك في خلل او هناك في مشكله
حقيقيه عند الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه طيب
ولكن لابد ان نشير الى ان هناك نوع من
مراجعه على الاقل في السياسه على الاقل
الاقتصاديه لان كنا نعتاد على طريقه لان
الان نحن امام اول مصدر النفط وامام اول
مستورد للنفط في العالم اذا هي علاقه
مصالح اوكي ولكن فيه استراتيجيه قد تغيرت
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
انا اعتقد الاستراتيجيه تغيرت الى المصلحه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي الاهم ولا
الاولويه قراءه حقيقه لان مهما كان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لديها ااا لديها
مشاريع ولديها مشروع ضخم لديها رؤيه 20 30
وايهما ايضا مصلحتها الاقتصاديه ومصالحها
ايضا كذلك الجنسيه لذلك الاهميه هي
للمصلحه السعوديه وليست المصلحه لاي دوله
اخرى على ان السعوديه تحترم علاقات مع
الدول وايضا تحترم حلفها مع الدول الاخرى
وشاركاتها مع الدول الاخرى لكن ايضا هو
الاهميه للمصلحه السعوديه لو نظرنا الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اول الصين او
لروسيا اي الدول ان تجد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لديها علاقه جيده ولديها محافظه
ايضا كذلك على مصالحها السعوديه لديها
علاقه جديده مع روسيا لديها علاقه جديده
مع الصين لديها العلاقه الجديده مع الغرب
مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن بحدود
ان لا تجاوز على المصالح السعوديه ولا
تتدخل ايضا في الشعر السعودي لان هذه
سياده ولا تقبل اي دوله اتدخل بسيادتك حتى
الدول يعني التي تدعي حتى الحريه حينما
يتدخل الموضوع الدوله فتنتظر حتى الشعب
جميعا ولذلك السعوديه لا تقبل ان يتدخل
احد في شؤونها الداخلي او قراءتها سياديه
هي تحترم هذه العلاقات لكن ايضا يجب ان
تحترم العادات والعلاقات والعرف الموجوده
في هذه الدول لا يعني لا تجبرني او لا
تحاول انك يعني همم تجبر هذه الدول على
الدول اولاد الشعوب لا ماتوا فيه انت اخت
توفيق تؤمن باشياء همم عندنا عادات عندنا
تقاليد عندنا معينه احنا لا نفرض هذه على
الدول وايضا كذلك نحترم الدول ولا نريد
مثل ماذا يريد ان يفعل الغرب
طيب ولكن نبدا من السعوديه اعتادت على
ثلاث قمم فيها في في قمه واحده باعتبارا
سبقه والنظمه القمه العربيه والخليجيه
والاسلاميه في في مكه ولكن لو نخرج من
الاطار الثنائي هذه الزياره فيها رسائل
اخرى
ان تنظم مع الصين قمه مع دول الخليج التي
تعاون الخليجي ثم ان تنظم ايضا قمه صينيه
عربيه في الرياض يعني هذا فيه لك اكثر
المغزله لا يمكن ان نتوقف فقط عن مساله
المصالح السريه هناك استراتيجي عربيه ايضا
هناك محاوله لاستعاده الدور السعودي في
المنطقه
اعتقد الدوري السعودي هو موجود ومؤثر
يعني سابقها قمم كثيره عملتها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
يعني مثلا الرئيس اوباما المجال المملكه
الدور الذي تقوم به السعوديه الدوله وازنه
مهمه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط في المحيط على
الاقليمي والدولي ونعرف نقرا المملكه
العربيه السعوديه السعوديه وهي عضو في ضمن
قائمه ال20 فلذلك السعوديه تعرف ان هناك
ادوار منوطه بها تقوم بها حتى عنده دول
المنطقه يعني احنا يعني يعني الحديث ولي
العهد السعودي اعتقد يمكن راجعه انه يريد
ان يتكون من منطقه الشرق الاوسط هي رب
العالمين لذلك حتى نرى بعض ال- ال-
المشاريع اللي تقوم بها السعوديه هي تحاول
حتى كذلك ان تكون ايضا شموريه بمعنى يكون
حتى ايضا تضم الدول الاخرى يعني بمعنى
تدخل قائمه الاردن مصر وهذا اعلن راينا
مثلا حديث في لما زار اليونان ربما حضرتك
انا مشروع ايضا كذلك ان توصل همم تكون
السعوديه مصدر الطاقه النظيفه الى اوروبا
عن طريق شراكات ايضا مع الدول المحيطه
احنا ما ننسى ان الدول ايضا المحيطه في
المنطقه ايضا هي تريد تبحث ايضا يكون
لديها استقرار ويكون عندها ازدهار
وعندهموم والسعوديه ايضا هي تعرف لها دور
محوري مهم جدا في المنطقه وهي قائد في هذه
المنطقه لذلك يا ترى من المهم او ان هي
تبادر ايضا كذلك اللي مثل هذه المشاريع
التي تقوم في النهضه المجتمعات والمنطقه
بشكل كامل
زيد بالكامل من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك